cool testing 1 2 3 4 danela hey nice to
meet it's amazing to see you in person
in person you're incredible yeah so so
what's up how you have you enjoyed the
conference so far really really good so
I've just been chatting with David
Charmers for the last half an hour which
is like meeting one of my heroes I'm so
pleased about that amazing it was so
good was so NE like in the community I
think something like with some you know
theoretical grounding in the
conversation because it feels like
everybody's on Twitter saying things but
nobody has like you know real authority
to talk about this stuff but now like he
was a very welcome know
that it was amazing so anyway the
emerging show is one of my favorite
shows that that we ever did and um so
Daniela your your last NPS was the um
the graph cellular autometa which we
spoke about on the show it opened up my
eyes to Cellular autometer and also all
of the mean there's a whole intellectual
Journey with cellular autometer you know
starting from the game of life on on a
regular grid going up to what you've
done which is the grass celling
autometer so that was absolutely amazing
but um since then you've been doing all
sorts of things so just give us an
update bring us up to date since our
lastation different things so uh since
we've spoken uh I've joined epfl as a
postto uh and I've been working on well
two main things uh one is the idea of
neural fields or implicit neural
presentations which is the paper we have
here uh and this is like this
fascinating again a little bit of exotic
type of machine learning where it's uh
it's very interesting it's you can
studed from like a signal processing
perspective and uh as a generative
models and they're they're very like
interesting and again we're asking
questions about like what happens if you
change the geometry what happens if you
have a graph uh so that's been amazing
uh and in parallel I've been like
pivoted to um computational biology
structural biology uh working with the
lab of Bruno Korea and uh you know
designing new proteins uh trying to
again use some of this stuff some of the
INR stuff um to try and and create new
proteins and optimize them according to
some some design principles which has
been like really fascinating and it's
actually has opened this whole world to
me uh about like how you can really use
machine learning to make an impact in
the world uh which is like you know this
there is this immense uh chance of
applying AI to biology and Drug design
which is actually by the way I guess the
biggest update of all is that I will be
joining as a morphic Labs uh in in
January aming yeah so again with with
that idea of you know bringing AI to
trans form you know medicine biology and
in this case drug discovery which is
like this big uh monster of a problem
that you can uh use machine learning for
uh so it's been really exciting and you
know it's been exciting also to see the
the community here and uh what they've
been up to and a lot of people are now
looking at applying machine learning to
biology even more than before and uh and
so it's nice to see all of these
techniques actually starting to bleed
into the real world and and to make a
real change so what which techniques are
being used to apply machine learning to
biology oh so I would say the the
biggest one that's making an impact
right now is the fusion models uh so
generation generating like molecules or
generating like the ways that molecules
are in the in space or interact other
molecules yeah well well this is really
interesting so CU I understand the
diffusion model um as you know on on the
plane with pixels and is it a similar
trick to what you were doing before that
that it's possible to do it on a on a
gra understand so what people have been
doing is so a molecule is this like 3D
object right it it has like a
confirmation in space and it it lives in
this 3D domain um and so
it's it's been nice to see the community
come up with this diffusion models for
putting points in space in a way that
makes chemical sense right and doing so
maybe if you have a Target in mind you
want to create a particular molecule for
a particular protein or a Target and
then you kind of diffuse this 3D
structure in a way that makes chemical
sense which has been like of course a
big challenge to overcome uh so there's
a lot of that coming coming up recently
which is like super exciting of course
uh inrs again what I've been working on
of course uh they starting to make an
appearance also in this space there are
works even here on cryo em so the rec
construction of protein structure from
like protein pictures let's say they
take pictures of proteins Frozen in some
medium and they try to reconstruct the
3D structure um that has been of course
fascinating because again it ties to
what I've been working on uh but again
many different application graph neural
networks of course they always are up
there in the you know applications of
graphs to to the protein world or the
the molecule world is uh they've been
great so yeah I mean lots of stuff to do
lots of lots of work lots of science
let's say amazing well can let's just
imagine that I've just I'm a random
person I've come up to your poster could
you like present your poster oh let's do
that so let's do it let's go let's go
ahead
um okay you come oh yeah we're good
we're good so the idea is this like so
uh there is something called an implic
neural representation which is this nice
idea uh of representing signals as
continuous functions so there are two
keywords here implicit uh is opposed to
explicit so an explicit signal is a way
of representing an image as like a
collection of pixels or an audio signal
is a collection of audio samples for
example and you store all of them in
memory so an implicit version of signal
uh would be a way of writing down a
function f ofx that gives you the output
of your signal without storing all the
sampol right so it's it's like an
analytic version of a of a signal now of
course if the signal is complex enough
you don't know how to write down this
function but luckily we have neural
networks that are very good at doing
this so if we have the explicit version
we can supervise a neural network uh to
to give us this implicit analytical
function um and this is what you call an
INR in general right in the ukl case now
as it often happens in geometric deep
learning you can ask the question of
okay I have a grid here what happens if
instead I have a graph right so if I
have a graph signal instead of like a
grid signal um so you ask that question
and and and the problem Remains the Same
you still want to find a continuous
implicit version of a graph signal but
you be need to be careful because now
you don't have coordinates anymore so
your F ofx you don't know what x looks
like right um so the way we solve this
problem is actually by looking uh at
some thing uh called a positional
encoding uh that on the graph this can
be computed by looking at the igen
vectors of the graph La plasan a bit
technical if you're like let's say we're
we're assuming you don't know anything
but
like in essence what these are is they
are oscillating functions that make
sense on a graph so with the all the
irregularities that the graph may have
and you can use this as positional
encoding so as like Signs and cosiness
in this case in a general graph version
of it right and so you can use this as
your coordinates and now you can fit
your implicit sign
and once you do this well now you can do
interesting things right uh so for
example one thing you can do is uh like
in this case up here uh you can model
spatial temporal signals so you have
this kind of graph structure or you know
surface in this case uh and you have a
signal that's evolving on it uh and so
now you can use a neural network to give
you the spatial temporal signal in an
implicit way and this is cool because
now what you can do is you can super
resolve the signal for example over
space and over time and you get a very
good performance if you do that and at a
fixed cost so this is you know the the
amount of uh things you need to save on
disk to store this signal is just the
weight so it's a constant cost and you
get infinite resolution as opposed to
storing all the samples so it's quite
nice and it works for for samples on any
on any kind of graph uh you can solve uh
differential equations if you want uh
which is something you do also in the
classical case but we show it for the
for the graph case um and then one nice
application we do here is uh modeling uh
weather signal so in in this case the
non uclean domain is a sphere it's the
Earth uh and the spatial temporal signal
is like cloud coverage or temperature or
winds over time and again what you can
do is you can fit a single neural
network to model that signal and then
you can super resolve right which has
been like has got a lot of people
excited in in the weather modeling
Community now casting and community and
stuff like that uh because of course
it's it's a very compact way of storing
huge amounts of data and now you only
have a single neural network that does
this so very exciting um very exciting
applications uh for the future we're
actually trying to apply this to like uh
modeling uh proteins uh modeling complex
signals some proteins so you know stay
tuned for like all the work that will
come amazing yeah Daniela thank you so
much hey thanks him it's been it's I
really appreciate it nice one nice one